[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
اثنين اسود على موسكو بمقتل 63 جنديا بدون
نتراب المعارك من حدودها
[تصفيق]
في ذكرى مقتل سليماني محتجوا ايران يحرقون
صوره ومعارضون خارج يدعونا الى اعلان
20/02 23 عام النصر
في تونس اضراب يشل العاصمه شركات نقل
تتوقف عن العمل وسط مصاعب ماليه ومخاوف من
الافلاس
وسيكون لدينا ايضا في العربيه 360 هذه
الليله
رونالدو يصلوا الليله الى الرياض وسط
تفاعل سعودي كبير مع انضمام الدون لنادي
النصر
[موسيقى]
يوما بعد يوم تاخذ الحرب في اوكرانيا منحا
تصعيديا سواء بالمعارك او حتى السلاح
المستخدم والاهم الخسائر البشريه تصريحات
لافته لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم اعترفت
فيها بمقتل ثمانيه وسبعون جنديا بهجوم
اوكرانيه على معسكر تجنيد مؤقت في منطقه
في مكيف كابيدونيس ك- شارقه اوكرانيا
وذكرت الوزاره ان الهجوم الاوكراني تم
تنفيذه بصواريخ هاي مارس شديده الانفجار
وان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين منها ما
يقلقوا الروس ليس ما يجري داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وان كانت حصيله اليوم ثقيله
على موسكو لكن الخطر الاكبر لروسيا هو
اقتراب المعارك من اراضيها بحسب ما نقل
مراسل العربيه في موسكو لنا اليوم
تقتربوا الحرب الاوكرانيه من الاراضي
الروسيه اذا بشكل تدريجي نتحدث هنا عن حرب
المسيرات تحديدا الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الطويله ومفتوحه جغرافيا تمتد
على طول
2063 كم من المناطق الروسيه القريبه
للحدود الاوكرانيه اقليم بريانكا الذي
اعلن حاكمه اليوم ان مسيره اوكرانيه
استهدفت منشاه للطاقه دون وقوع اصابات
واضاف ان المسيره تنفذته هجوما على منطقه
كليموفيسكي دون وقوع اصابات الا ان مرافق
الطاقه تضررت ما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء
عن المنطقه
[موسيقى]
هذا في بريانكا لكن هناك مناطق اخرى
مدينه فارونيج
على المدينه التي تبعد عن الحدود 300 كيلو
متر طائره مسيره اعلنت موسكو اسقاطها من
قبل الدفاعات الجويه قبل وصولها الى
المدينه بينما افادت صفحات غير رسميه بان
الطائره سقطت وكان بالامكان سماع دوي
الانفجار مقاطع اخرى ايضا قريبه جدا من
الحدود الاوكرانيه اذا هذه مقاطعه قريبه
جدا من الحدود وهي
بالقرود تعرضت مرارا لهجوم بمسيرات
اوكرانيه ضربت احداها مولد الكهرباء ما
ادى الى انقطاع الخدمه عن اجزاء من
المدينه الرئيس الروسيه
في الحادي والثلاثين من ديسمبر عندما كان
في مدينه تروس الحدوديه او عزا للحكومه
بتطوير الانظمه الجويه للمسيرات وقال ان
الهدفه هو تنفيذ سياسه الدوله بهذا المجال
اضافه الى حل المشكلات المتعلقه بتطوير
وانتاجه واعتمادي وتشغيل الانظمه الجويه
غير الماهوله محددا الخامس عشر من فبراير
موعدا اقصى للتنفيذ
[موسيقى]
معنى للمزيد من التفاصيل من دنياتك مراسل
العربيه رائد الاخضر ومن موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بكما ابدا
معك رائد واي تحديث عندك
الارقام او عدد القتلى الكبير الذي اعلن
عنه ويحكى ان العدد اكبر منه بكثير
بدايه طاهر يعني الرقم الذي ذكره يعني
ذكرته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وهو 63 مقاتلا
الله الرسمي حتى الان لكن الوكاله او
المرصد المحلي هنا في مقاطعه ادانه اعلن
عن 78 قتيل وقال بان هناك 136
اضافه الى كثيرون او
كثيرات ما زالت وزاره الطوارئ تبحث عن
ناجينا من هؤلاء الذين ما زالوا يقبعونا
تحت الانقاق
ايضا عبد الجواد الرشد ثم اعود اليك هل من
تحديث
لاعداد قتلى عندك في موسكو عبد الجواد
مساء الخير يا طاهر لك ولي رائد حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت وزاره الدفاع تتحدث عن
ثلاثه و60 جنديا قتلوا لكن اسمح لي طاهر
بالاشاره بان العديد من الانباء والعديد
من التقارير العسكريه غير الرسميه تتحدث
عن ان دانيتكم كيف تعرضت لهذه الضربه في
ليله راس السنه ليله راس السنه من 31 من
ديسمبر الماضي حتى الاول من مطلع هذا
العام نفذت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذه
الضربه لكن الاعلان عنها رسميا جرى اليوم
طبعا الكثير من المواقع تتحدث عن هذا
الشيء هي صواريخ هايمارس كما يتحدثون اربع
منها طبعا وصلت الى تلك المنطقه وصرخان تم
اسقاطهم بانظمه الدفاع
المعلومات عندك قصف همم رائد
مستمر بين قناتين القصف شديد جدا ومستمر
منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى الان لا يتوقف
القصر طاهر القصر متبادل يعني لا بدنا لا
نميز بين القضيفه التي تخرج من المقاطعه
والقذيفه التي تسقط حولنا في احياء
المقاطعه لكن بالفعل هناك سقوط لاكثر من
400 او 500 قذيفه وصاروا نضيفنا بان ال
يعني الاله العسكريه الاوروبيه والغربيه
التي بدا يستخدمها الاجانب الاوكراني هناك
صواريخ تشيكيه وراجمات صواريخ بولنديه
بدات تدخل نطاق العمل في هذه المعارك
وبدات يعني تؤثر في مسار الحرب والمعارك
هناك بالفعل سكون همم طوال اليومين او
ثلاثه ايام الماضيه في المدينه شوارع
خاويه بالفعل ليست هناك اي مظاهر من
الاحتفال في ذكرى راس السنه الميلاديه او
حتى
قاعد الناس هنا يعانون بالفعل من الخطر
الشديد يعني كنت اخرج في المباشر من
الشارع لكن الشارع كان خطرا جدا فرتاينا
ان نخرج من الشرفه وحتى الان من الشرفه
القس ما زال مستمرا ولا اعلم اذا كنتم
تسمعون يعني صدى اصوات كنت اسمع شيئا منه
بينما كان عبد الجواد يتحدث سلامتك اولويه
همم في هذه التغطيه همم رائد شكرا جزيلا
على كل جهودك اتحول من جديد الى عبد
الجواد الرشد واسالك عن فكره الانعطافه
التي تحدثنا عنها سابقا اليوم همم يبدو ان
هناك عطافه بشكل واضح في مسار هذه الحرب
خاصه ما ذكرناه قبل قليل لجهه قلق موسكو
من اقتراب همم المعارك من حدودها اكثر
طاهر صحيح ما تقوله الحرب والاعمال
القتاليه في الارض تحولت اليوم على نطاق
واسع الى الضربات الصاروخيه والى المسيرات
التي اصبحت الجانبان
يستخدمها خلال يعني ضرباته ان كانت على
الاراضي الروسيه او على الجانب الاوكراني
ما نلاحظه اليوم هو القلق الكبير واشتعال
الشريط الحدود من اوله لاخره بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بدايه من مقاطعه بلغراد التي
يعني نتابع على مدار الساعه تحديث الاخبار
فيها والتي تتحدث عن سقوط قذيفه ما في احد
الاماكن او صاروخ في مكان اخر او وصول
مسيره تضرب احدى النقاط لي الطاقه في
المدينه او في ضواحيها لكن ما يقلق الشارع
الروسي اليوم هو طبعا وصول المسيرات الى
نقاط ابعد من الشريط الحدودي وكما ذكرت
طالب هي فارونج التي تبعد قرابه خمسه مئه
كم غرب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وهي ليست
ببعد كثيره عن الحدود الاوكرانيه لكن
مسافه 300 كم ان تطير المسيره وهذا السؤال
الذي طرحه كثيرون من قراء السياسه اليوم
في البلاد كيف لهذه المسيره ان تصل في ظل
الوضع الرهن والمراقبه الشديده التي
تفرضها موسكو على الشريط الحدود مع مع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ايضا على سبيل المثال
طاهر هناك مسيرات كانت قد وصلت الى صلاتك
والتي تقع في جنوب شرق موسكو وهي بعيده
كثيره عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه ما يخيف هو
طبعا تشغيل هذه المسيرات من الداخل لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه الاعلان الرسمي عن ان هذه
السيارات تنطلق وتطير من الاراضيه
الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات عبد الجواد الرسل مراسل العربيه
مراسل العربيه
ان شاء الله
اثنين اسود وداما اجبره موسكو على الاعلان
عن حصيلتي هجوم او مجزره مكيفكه غير
المسبوقه منذ بدء الحرب او العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لم يسبق ان ابلغ
الجيش الروسي الذي نادرا ما يعطي ارقام
عن عدد القتلى والجرحى في صفوفه
اربعه صواريخ هاي مارس ضربت مركزا انتشار
مؤقت للجيش الروسي في مدينه مكيفك الواقعه
التي تحتلها القوات الروسيه روسيه تعتبر
انها ضمتها وهي بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا
ضرب النظام
امريكيه الصنع مركزه تجمع الوحدات القوات
المسلحه الروسيه قرب مستوطنه في جمهوريه
اليوسف الشعبيه اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه صاروخين من نوعه مارس ونتيجه
لتدمير مركز التجمع باربعه الصواريخ براس
حربي شديد انفجار قتل 63 جنديا روسيا
وسيتم تقديم كل المساعده والدعمين لاقارب
واصدقاء الجنود الذين سقطوا
لكن كيف حدث الهجوم وكيف استطاعت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا هدفها بدقه الجواب
نقلته وكاله الانباء الروسيه تاس قائله
تمت الضربه بعد ان سمح استخدام الجنود
الذين وصلوا
استخدام هواتفهم المحموله بكثافه للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي
استخدامهم للهواتف للجيش الاوكراني بتحديد
موقعهم هذه الحادثه اعدتنا الى بدايه
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا صدرت وقتها
تقارير تحديدا بدايه من شهر مارس الماضي
حول اعتماد القوات الروسيه بشكل متكرر
ومفاجئ على اجهزه اتصال غير امنه كالهواتف
الذكيه واجهزه الراديو التي تعمل بنظام
الضغط للتحدث ما ترك الوحدات عرضه
للاستهداف بعد شهر من الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا صحيفه واشنطن بوستا نقلت عن
مسؤول امريكي ان الروس سيستخدمون الكثير
من الاتصالات غير السريه وان الاتصالات
السريه ليست قويه كما ينبغي لها ان تكون
الاخطر من ذلك كله ما نقله محللون عن ان
عمليات البث العسكريه الروسيه عبر خطوط
غير امنه منتشره لدرجه انه هواه الراديو
قد يستمعون اليها عبر الانترنت باستخدام
مواقع مثل ويب اس دي ار حادثه اليوم
تذكرنا بحادث مشابهه وقعت في مارس الماضي
قتل فيها جنرال روسي بغاره جويه بعد ان
اكتشفه الاوكرانيون عبر هاتفه المحمول
وفي حاله اخرى شاركتها وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه سابقا سمع اثنان من مسؤولين
استخبارات الروسيه وهما يناقشان على نطاق
واسع وفت ضابط كبير وعندما طلب احدهم
التحدث على خط مشفر قال الاخر انه لا يعمل
[موسيقى]
معنى من باريس البحث في العلاقات الدوليه
والمتخصص في الشان الروسي محمد سيف الدين
اهلا بك معنا استاذ سيف الدين كيف نفسر ما
حصل في دنياز
تاكيد هناك تفسيرات عسكريه تقنيه لها
علاقه بالتطور الاتصالات لدى الطرف
الاوكراني وقدرته على اكتشاف
المواقع التي يعني
يتجمع فيها جنودروس وهناك مشكلات تقنيه
ايضا في وفي منظومه الاتصال عند القوات
الروسيه وكان الرئيس الروسي ووزير دفاعي
اشاره الى الحاجه لتطوير هذا القطاع في
الاجتماع الذي جرى في وزاره الدفاع قبل 10
ايام كما اعتقد
ويعني هذا يعبر عن تفاصيل تقنيه لهذا
الموضوع
في امور منذ بدايه الحرب حتى الان تعتبر
اساسيات في العمل العسكري وبعيدا عن العمل
السياسي يعني بغض النظر عنه ولكن في العمل
العسكري على الاقل همم البعض يسمي ذلك
اخطاء البعض يسميه اخفاقات تهاون
طار عدم وجود يعني خبره معينه في في
مواضيع معينه مثلا استخدام الهواتف يعني
بديهي نعم هي هي يعني هي شؤون واحداث كانت
ملحوظه خلال الاشهر الماضيه وتم الاعتراف
يعني ببعضها من الجانب الروسي ويتم ملاحظه
الكثير من هذه الاحداث من قبل المراقبين
ومحللين وهذا الامر كما قلت هو يعني موضع
عنايه الان لدى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ويحاولون يعني علاج هذا الامر لكن هناك
ايضا يعني في هذا السياق همم يجب ان ننظر
الى مستوى المعركه والى اطار المواجهه
الذي لا يشمل فقط القوات الموجوده في
لوغانس والقوات الاخرانيه وانما هو مواجهه
اكثر شمولا تشمل كل القدرات التي يضعها
يضعها النت في همم تصرف القوات الاخرانيه
ومن الجانب الروسي ايضا تشمل كل القدرات
التي يستطيع الجيش الروسي الدفع بها
لمحاوله الانتصار هذه المعركه لكن كنت
اتحدث عن المعنى السياسي لما يجري الان من
تصاعد وتيره الضربات العسكريه ويعني
ارتفاع ملحوظ في عدد
القتلى الذي يعني يحصد على الجانبين وهذا
الامر يعبر عن ملئ الفراغ السياسي وعدم
وجود لافق للحل السياسي وغياب القدره عن
اي قوه دوليه
للتقدم بطرح اول على الاقل لحل سياسي لما
يجري ما يحصل في مقابل ذلك هو ان المدفعيه
والطائرات المسيره والصواريخ البعيده هي
التي تمرا تملا هذا الفراغ
يعني يبدو في الاسابيع الاخيره وايضا كان
في الاسابيع الاولى للحرب لكن الان اكثر
الدور الاكبر للمسيرات الذي يعني يتناى
بشكل كبير جدا والذي يفاجئ في بعض المواضع
بان هذه المسيارات تمتلك قدرات اكبر مما
كان متصورا
هذا هل يعني تست روسيا كثيرا في هذه
المجالات همم لانه البعض بدا يقول انه ما
بدا يحصل في عام 20 23 هو انعطافه في مسار
هذه الحرب دعنا نتحدث يعني في الشق
المتعلق باطار بالعلاقات الدوليه والسياسه
هذا الفراغ الذي تحدثت عنه هل تعتقد انه
سيفرض المزيد من التصعيد او انه همم يعني
اشتدي ازمن خارجي فبالتالي يمكن اجبار
الجميع على محاوله ايجاد همم
حلمه على الاقل يعني خيط حل يتم الانطلاق
منه في مفاوضات نعم
يعني للاسف لنكون واقعين في موضوع يعني
الضحايا والقطله والمدنيين حتى الذين
يسقطون في هذه المواجهات ليست هي يعني ليس
هذا الموضوع الذي يحرك بشكل كبير جدا
اتجاه الحلول ما يدفع باتجاه الحلول وما
يمكن ان يشكل بارقه امل في اتجاه الحلول
هو الاوزار الاقتصاديه والمشكلات
الاقتصاديه التي تكبر عند كل الدول
المتحاربه الان وعلى ضفتي هذه المواجهه
هذا فقط ما يمكن ان يسرع بمصار الحل لان
القوه المشتركه في هذه المواجهه سوف تصل
الى مرحله ما لا تستطيع تحمل اعباء هذه
الحرب وبدانا نرى هذه الامور في المؤشرات
والارقام في الاقتصاد العالم الذي يتجه
الى ازمات غير مسبوقه مستمر يعني او في
ترجيح لكافه على الاقل في نقاط معينه يعني
اذا تحدثنا عن ابرز نقطه او نقطتين قوه
وضعف لدى كل طرف عمنا نتحدث
نعم لدى القوات الاوكرانيه هناك يعني مكان
قوه لها علاقه
وهناك زخم جديد في الاسابيع الاخيره الان
يعني هذه الضربه تعبر عن هذا الزخم وهذه
الاشاره لا بد ان من الالتفات اليها لانه
هناك زخم يبدو من النت وخصوصا بعد زياره
سيلنسكي الى الى الولايات المتحده يبدو ان
هناك زخما عسكريا جديدا من ناحيه نوعيه
المعدات ومن ناحيه قدره الاوكرانيين على
يعني التسبب بضرر الروس في هذا السياق
بالنسبه للروس هناك يعني همم اذا اردنا ان
نقص في الامر هناك مساره متوازيين المسار
الاول مرتبط بقدره الروس على استخدام
الصواريخ البعيده والصواريخ الشديده
الانفجار والتي يتفوقون فيها في يعني وهذا
معروف قبل الحرب حتى وهناك المسار
الاقتصاد الاقتصادي الذي يضغطون به على
الغرب ويستغلون ايضا يعني تعطل امدادات
الطاقه اوروبا تحديدا وهذا الامر يدخن
ويعزز ويسرع يحدث حركه تسارع
للضغوط الاقتصاديه التي تسببها الحرب في
اوكرا وبالتالي هم يريدون تحويل المواجهه
في اوكرانيا الى اكبر قدر ممكن من الضغط
على يعني الاقتصادات الغربيه وهذا الامر
نسبيا يؤدي يؤدي كله لحتى لحتى هذه اللحظه
لكن هناك يعني همم موضوع موضوع المسيارات
وموضوع الخطه الروسيه التي اعلن عنها الان
هذه المسيارات وتطويرها ايضا همم لافت جدا
ويمكن ان يؤدي الى تغييرات لكن اعتقد ان
المواجهه سوف تشتد من الان وحتى الربيع
المقبل على الاقل على المستوى الميداني
لان في هذه الفتره تتحدث عن فصل كامل لا
يمكن ان نتحدث عن معطيات حقيقيه لصحيح لحل
سياسي
طبيعه هذه الحرب لا شيء لا يمكن حسم هذه
المعركه الان تمام تمام
يمكن التوقع حسم من قبل احد الطرفين في
هذه الاشهر ثلاث قبل ان تاتي حمله كبرى من
احد الطرفين وتنتظر حمله روسيه في هذا
الامر تتحدث عنها الصحف العالميه وهناك
معطيات على هذا الامر لكن اريد ان اشير
الى نقطه مهمه جدا وهي التي تعيق حتى الان
همم يعني نهايه هذه الازمه او وضع تصور
لانها هذه الازمه وهي غياب قوه دوليه
موثوقه قادره على التقدم للاعب دور الوسيط
مع انخراط كل العالم الغربي تقريبا في هذه
المواجهه ضد روسيا ومع همم يعني همم روسي
يعني سقف التوقعات من هذه الازمه هناك
غياب بدور همم راعي الطريق
او الطريق الذي يمكن ان يكون صله توصل لها
وقت نهائيا الاستاذ محمد بدك ان يشكل
البيئه لهذا الصراع شكرا
جزيلا لكم استاذ محمد سيف الدين الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه والمتخصص في شان الروسيه
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
عشيه الذكرى الثالثه لمقتل محتجون في عدد
من الشوارع الايرانيه يحرقون صورا لقاسم
سليمان لانه متابع بعضها
في الشارع الايرانيه امال عريضه على العام
الجديد مجموعه من الشخصيات المعارضه
المقيمه في المنفى نشرت رساله تتوقع بان
يكون 20 23 بان يكون عام 20 23 عام النصر
على النظام ولا طالما اعتبرت المعارضه في
المنفى اعتبرت مشرذمه ومنقسمه في التعامل
مع النظام الحاكم منذ 79 لكن في ظل
الاستمرار الاحتجاجات يبدو ان الامر يتغير
في مضمون الرساله رساله العام 20 22 كان
رائعا لجهه تضامن الايرانيين من كل معتقد
ولغه وانه مع التنظيم والتضامن سيكون عام
20 23 عام مصر للامه الايرانيه هذا ما
تعتبره المعارضه في الخارج الان الرساله
نشرتها بشكل متزام على لتواصل شخصيات عدا
انطلاقا من المعارضه البارزه مسيح علي
نجاد وصولا الى نجل الشاه الراحل رضا
البحلاوي
كما نشرت الممثلتان الشهيرتان اكتشفت
فرحاني ونذانين بن يدي الرساله اضافه الى
زهره امير ابراهيم التي نال جائزه افضل
ممثله في مهرجان كان السينمائي العام
الماضي وكتبت فرحاني على حسابها في
انستغرام نقف صفا واحدا للوصول الى الحريه
سنقف معا ولن نلزم الصمت تضم قائمه
الناشطين مدافعين عن حقوق الانسان الذين
نشره الرساله شيرين عبادي الحق اذا جائزه
نوبل للسلام وحامد اسماعيل الذي قاد حمله
مقرها كندا للمطالبه للعداله لضحايا رحله
الخطوط الجويه الاوكرانيه التي اسقطتها
ايران في يناير 20
اما في مجال الرياضه فنشر الرساله نجم كره
القدم الدولي السابق علي كريمه وهو احد
ابرز مؤيدي الحركه الاحتجاجيه
الرساله اخذت صدا واسعا لدى الايرانيين
واعتبرها معارض ايراني انها مؤشر يبعث على
الامل في فتره مظلمه فهل يكون عام 20 23
عاما النصر
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في ايران لكن خارجيا حيث اكد وزير
خارجيه اسرائيل الجديده لكوهين في كلمته
الاولى بعد استلام مهامه اكدزامه بلاده
بمنع ايران من الحصول على قدرات النوويه
عسكريه وان اسرائيل ستعمل على تطوير
قدراتها لمواجهه اي سيناريو ايراني
مدينه اسرائيل ملتزمه بمنع ايران من
الحصول على قدره النوويه عسكريه باي وسيله
على خلفيه الاجماع الدوليه على ان الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لم يعد جدول سنركز على
جانب تعزيز القدرات الامنيه المستقله لاي
سيناريو في محاوله لتشكيل جبهه دوليه لمنع
البرنامج النووي الايراني ان تصرفات ايران
لا تنعكس فقط في طموحها لامتلاك اسلحه
النوويه بل تنعكس ايضا في مشروع الصواريخ
بعيده المدام مثل الطائرات بدون طيار
وتمويل الارهاب الدولي ويجيبوا على دول
العالم ان تتوقف عن دفن رؤوسها في الرمال
في العربيه 360 ايضا اقتصاد العالم في 20
23 امام خمسه سيناريوهات نستعرضها بعد
الفاصل فارجو ان تبقى معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تونس شل اضرابون حركه
النقل البري في العاصمه وتوقفت معها حركه
المترو والحافلات بعد ان بدا موظفوا شركه
النقل الحكوميه اضرابا للاحتجاج على
التاخر في دفع المكافات والاجور كما تقرر
تاجيل الامتحانات في بعض الجامعات
التونسيه تزامنا مع الاضراب في قطاع النقل
[موسيقى]
في محطه الجمهوريه بتونس العاصمه وجد كمال
نفسه ينتظر ساعات طوال عله يظفر بوسيله
نقل تقله الى منزله حيث زوجته المريضه
بانتظاره
نقل عموميه تلاجه ولا المتر الخفيف يشتغل
بسبب اضراب عمال شركه نقل تونس
المتزامن مع اضراب سائق التكسي الفرديه
النقل
تونسيين تقطعت بهم السبل البعض يلهث وراء
وسيله نقل خاصه وخير البعض الذهاب الى
العمل او الدراسه مشيا على الاقدام وسط
حاله من الغضب والاحتقال
ما احد شيء صدقني شيء اسف وشيء حزن وليدي
هنا واحده من الناس هابتل تونس معنيه
نصفكم في المروج هفضل تونس همت منكم حتى
على بعضهم
واللي جاي يمشي يمشي
لمده شهرين
التي تواجهها الشركات العامه
وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس
للحديث اكثر معنا من تونس خليل الرقيقه
المحلل السياسي التونسيه اهلا بك معنا
استاذ خليل
لماذا
الامور عن نطاق ما كان مجدلا سابقا
بالنسبه الى انتظار ال ال الدراب المقبل
المحدد انفا
الحقيقه هذا ثاني اضراب من نوعه لنفس
القطاع في ظرف شهر نتذكر جيدا ان هناك
اضرابا فجيا قامت به عمال شركه نقل تونس
بدعوه من النقابه من الاتحاد شغل منذ شهر
وقد تسبب في نفس تقريبا ماساه الانسانيه
التي رايناها الان في تقريركم بمعنى
المشكله ليس في المطالب في حد ذاتها لانه
في الاضراب الذي سبق وقع صرف المرتب
متاخرا ببعض الايامى عن موعد صرفه المعتاد
يعني اذا كانت المساله مساله مرتب ومساله
الشاعر خلال شهر مكافاه ووصوله اكل لا
يمكن ان تصل الى ادرار في وجهي يوم العوده
المدرسيه مباشره بعد عطله الشتاء
تعرف يعرف عمال النقل اكثر من غيرهم انه
يبتسم بمعانات ومتشابكه
المواد الاساسيه والادويه يعني المواطن
اصلا كان مهيا للمعاناه اليوم في الحقيقه
المساله التي مسها جوهريا هي المواطنون
الضعفاء والبساء يعني ماذا تريد ان تقول
سلطه معلش ماذا يعني ذلك انت تلومهم همم
انت تلومهم يعني ما كان يجب عليهم ان يقوم
بحقيقه او ان يعلنوه على الاقل تقصد
نعم نعم اجد نفسي في معرض ربما هذا اللون
او في ربما
تفاهمي لما طالب المهنيه للقطاعات الحيويه
في تونس كقطاع النقل رغم التفاهم التاخير
صار في الجرائد كان يمكن تفاديه ولكن
اليوم ايضا يعني بمناسبه عوده من دورين
النقابين اذا المدرسه بمناسبه انه هناك
شغالين يتبنى الاتحاد معاناتهم يذهبون
يوميا باكرا الى العمل هذه الفجائيه في
الاذراف في الحقيقه لم تغضب فقد جزءا من
الشارع التونسي هل اراد ان يكون ذلك
فجائيه ليحدث همم ما احداثه فعلا ليحدث
هذا الوقع
لنكون صوره حاء وواقعي يعني اليوم تصريحات
المكلفه بالاتصال في شركه نقل تونس
والتصريح مدير الشركه يقول ان الجرايه
سوري فته في اواخر الاسبوع وقد تتاخر
اياما يعني لامور اداريه بحث تخص البنوك
بمعنى انني لا يمكن ان افصل اضراب اليوم
عن حاله الغضب ليس فقط في النقل بل حاله
الغضب داخل الاتحاد الشغل نفسه وداخل
قياده اتحاد الشغل على الوضع السياسي في
البلاد لا يمكن ان افصل هذا الاضرار عن
المبادره الثلاثيه التي يريد اتحاد شغل
تمريره الان وهمم لتعزيز موقعه التفاوض في
هذه المبادله حيث يعني لديه مطالب
اجتماعيه وسياسيه الملاكفه ما بين الحكومه
والاتحاد عادت بالوبال اليوم على
المواطنين وهذا راي الخاص ولا اعتقد ان
هناك صدفه في وجود قويه في قطاعات مؤثره
مثل هذه في مثل هذا التوقيت الذي تشهد فيه
العلاقه بين السلطه والاتحاد توتر مبالغا
ذهب الى حد التلويح بالتسعيط من طرف
المناظمه الشغيله وهو اعتقد انها بواكير
هذا التصعيد التي ستمسك ساعات اخرى ندرك
ان الاتحاد له ثالوث معروف قوي هو الصحه
والنقل والتعليم كل هذه القطاعات تشهد
تملم الان وربما يتوسع الامر ايضا قطاع
النقل يريد ان يوسع المعركه الى التضامن
النقابي بمعنى الى قطاع النقل الجوي والى
قطع النقل الحديدي انك مشاولات الان
لتوسيع يعني افق هذا الاضراب الى قطاعات
اخرى استراتيجيه ما معنى ذلك ان سننتقل من
معركه مرتبات وهي معركه جزئيه قد تحل في
يوم وليله الى معركه ربما اكثر استراتيجيه
واكثر استراليا
وهو ما يخشى منه ايضا الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل لجهه طبيعتها وفحواها خاصه
اذا همم ما شملت بعضا من الخصخصه
نعم وخاصه في في جانب الشركات العموميه
ولكن اخي يجب ان نتذكر جيدا ان اخر تصريح
لرئيس الجمهوريه في هذا المجال امام رئيس
الحكومه في اجتماعا معلن وواضح وخارج عنه
بيان يقول انه لا التفريته في المؤسسات
العموميه اذا معركه المؤسسات العموميه
نعرفها في تونس هذه الشركه بالتحديد وهي
الشركه عموميه بالكامل هي شركه تقريبا
خاسر ماليا وشركه لديها صعوبات وتضطر
الدوله اذا دخل اموال من اجل المرتبات
يعني صعوبات القطاع العموميله
وامام السلطه ولكن فكره التفريت هذه ايضا
تدخل في المعركه السياسيه اكثر منها فكره
حقيقيه لانه لا يوجد اي بلاغه رسمي او
بيان رسمي من الدوله التونسيه يقول انه تم
التفريط في شركه واحده او سيتم ذلك حانون
الماليه لسنه 23 لم يتضمن يعني حتى ربع
شركه للبيع شركه عموميه بل تتضمن مساله
اسمه اعاده الهيكل يتفق حول هذه الجماعه
اذن
في نهايه هذا الشهر الخامس والعشرين
والسادس والعشرين يناير للجامعه العامه
للنقل لاضافه الى اضرابات اخرى في
القطاعات المختلفه الاخرى التي ذكرتها
نتابعها معكم شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس خليل
رقيق المحلل سياسي تونسي من هناك تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
تحديات العام الجديد 20/3 23
الاقتصاديه تحديدا محور دائم للتحليل
والشد والجذب خصوصا بعد عام من الاحداث
السلبيه منها ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وازمه
الطاقه والغذاء وكاله بلومبرج نشرت تقريرا
حمل خمسه سيناريوهات تنذر بمخاطر اقتصاديه
متوقعه استمرار ارتفاع التضخم باعتباره
احد المخاطر الرئيسيه 23 بينما لا يزال
المستقبل
للاسهم والسندات زياده قوه الدولار مع
ارتفاع تكاليف الاقتراض ما يهدد بحدوث
ركود
السيناريو الثاني الخوف من تعثر الصين رغم
ان الاسهم الصينيه قفزت بنحو 35% مع اتجاه
الصين لانهاء عمليات الاغلاق لكن هذه
المكاسب مهدده بسبب مخاطر ارهاق النظام
الصحي والسبب تفشي العدوى ولا يزال
الانتعاش في الاسهم الصينيهاشا واي احتمال
لتعثر النشاط الاقتصادي من شانه ان يضعف
الطلب في اسواق السلع الاساسيه خصوصا
بالنسبه للمعادن الصناعيه الحديث
السيناريو الثالث
القاتل استمرار حرب اوكرانيه مع تداعياتها
على الاقتصاد العالمي كل وازمه الطاقه كما
ان استمرار العقوبات على روسيا وداعيها قد
تؤدي الى تقليل المعروض في العالم فيما
يتعلق بالغذاء والطاقه اخرى مثل الاسمده
وبعض المعادن والكيماويات والسيناريو
الاكثر رعبا هو استخدام روسيا السلاح
النووي في اوكرانيا فمن شان ذلك انهاء
الصادرات الزراعيه الاوكرانيه بضربه واحده
لخامس اكبر مصدر للحبوب في العالم
السيناريو الرابع هو تراجع الاسواق
الناشئه يحذر التقرير من ان اي فشل في كبح
جناح التضخم من شانها ان يؤثر سلبا في
الاسواق الناشئه التي قد تعاني في 20 23
اذا استمر دولار في الارتفاع لان العديد
من البلدان الاسواق الناشئه لديها ديون
مقاومه بالدولار السيناريو الاخير عوده
الجائحه تكثر التحذيرات مؤخرا من ان ظهور
جديده اكثر عدوى لكوفيد نايتين او حتى
المتغيرات الحاليه التي تستمر لفتره اطول
قد يؤدي الى تعطيل سلاسل التوريد مره اخرى
وبالتالي قد يؤدي الى زياده التضخم والى
تباطؤ النشاط الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
رونالدو يصل الليله الى الرياض وسط تفاعل
سعودي كبير مع انضمام الدول لنادي النصر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نصرا نجم البرتغالي و
لاعب نادي النصر السعودي كريستيانو
رونالدو فيديو عبر حسابه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وهو في طريقه الى
الرياض للانضمام الى الفريق ووجه الاسطوره
البرتغاليه رساله الى جماهير النصر عبر
حسابه على انستغرام وهو في الطائره الخاصه
المتجهه الى العاصمه السعوديه قائلا اراكم
قريبا
[موسيقى]
بضم النجم البرتغالي اثار التفاعلا
وارقاما قياسيا الصفقه غيرت مفاهيم كثيره
فما هي الا ساعات قليله حتى تضعفت اعداد
متابعي نادي النصر في منصه انستغرام ليظهر
في خانه الملايين وصل ايضا الان النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو الى العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض
الانضمام الى ناديه الجديد نادي النصر
بصفقه التي تمت مؤخرا واعلن عنها ومن
المنتظر ان يكون هناك حفل همم في ملعب
نادي النصر حفل ضخم همم يتحدث فيه
كريستيانو رونالدو
لجماهيره في نادي النصر وللجماهير
السعوديه اضافه الى الكثير من التوقعات
بالاجواء الايجابيه وبتداعيات الايجابيه
التي
تسهم هذه الصفقه باحداثها في يتعلق
باستذاب لاعبين اخرين بوضع نادي النصر
بلنجازات التي يمكن ان يحققها اا مع
انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو نحن سنتابع اخر
المعلومات والتفاصيل والصور انت وفرت
لوصول النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الى الرياض اذن ولكن نتابع فيما لدينا هذه
الملايين الجديده التي نتحدث عنها على
الانستغرام فقط لنادي النصر والتي تستمر
بازدياد كل ثانيه ليصل حتى قبل ساعتين من
الان تقريبا الى 6.7 مليون متابع ليس
الامر مستغربا فاللاعب يتابعه عبر حسابه
على انستغرام خمس مئه مليون حساب وحصد
صورته مع رئيس نادي النصر على اكثر من
واحد وثلاثين فاصل ثمانيه مليون اعجاب ضمن
اكثر ست صور اعجابا على المنصه في التاريخ
المقاس لقيته خلال يعني خمس دقائق عشر
دقائق
بخصوص الطباعه قال لي بعد ثلاث ايام وانت
عارف الحفله بكره فاضطريت اني اشوف اي محل
ثاني اني اطبع يعطيك الرقم والاسم واطلع
برا ما شاء الله هنا بالنسبه
رونالدو قبل رونالدو مع النصر يعني بس ما
شاء الله هنا سواء الابلكيشن او حتى في
المتجر نفسه الخدمه ما شاء الله يعني
سريعه وكل شيء متوفر يعني موجود حاليا
حتى انا طلبت الاسم لكن قالوا بعد ثلاث
ايام
ومع وصول النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو اذا اا الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض مع انضمامه الى نادي النصر بانتظار
الحفل الذي سيقام غدا الاستقبال اللاعب
الاعظم عالميا كما ااا يعرف كما قال النصر
متصدر الدوري السعودي للمحترفين لكره
القدم غدا الثلاثاء طبعا هناك الحدث
المنتظر كما وصف وكما قال النصر على حسابه
في تويتر مع الصوره اللاعب البرتغالي همم
حفل استقبال اللاعب الاعظم عالميا وهذا
الحفل اذا سيتم في ساحه النصر مرسول بارك
همم في همم الساعه 7:00 مساء همم طبعا كان
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو قد انتقل همم
الى مصر في صفقه تاريخيه همم علما ان
النصر يتصدر الدوري السعودي رصيد 26 نقطه
من 11 مباراه وبفارق واحده عن الشباب الذي
خضع عشر مباريات ونقطتين عن الاتحاد الذي
يملك ايضا مباراه واحده مؤجله طبعا هناك
الكثير من الايجابيات المرتبطه بهذه
الصفقه ولم تتوقف مكاسبها عند النصر بل
استمرت مسجله تقدما لافتا بحسب ارقام
ترانسفير ماركت جاء النادي ضمن افضل 120
ناديا عالميا كقيمه السوقيه ب 79.10 مليون
دولار الاول على صعيد انديه اسيا وافريقيا
لترتفع قيمته بالمجمل بارب 34% اضف الى
ذلك اسهام انتقال رونالدو الى مصر في
زياده عقود التجاريه والماليه للنادي اذ
ستجذب هذه الصفقه الكبرى الكبرى ايات
الشركات الاقتصاديه والتسويقيه من اجل
الاعلام عبر قميص النصر وملعب له تاريخ
حافل نقلات النوعيه التسويقيه فمثلا عند
انتقاله الى مانشستر يونايتد صيف 20 21
اصبح قميص رونالدو اسرع مبيعا في تاريخ
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز مسجلا ارقام
خياليه الامر نفسه سيسعى نصر لتحقيقه في
الملاعب السعوديه مع القميص رقم سبعه
لنجمه الجديد بعض حسابات السعوديين على
مواقع التواصل تحدثت عن بيع قميص رونالدو
مع النصر خلال الساعات فقط بقيمه وصلت
مليونير ريال
باينه على نادي النصر امام بصفقه انتقال
اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو الى
النادي العاصميه حتى بدات الانذار تتجه
الى
المتجر الرسمي لنادي النصر وهذا احد
المناظر ل مشجعين فرحين جدا بالحصول على
تيشيرت كريستيانو رونالدو في المتجر
الرسمي الذي تباع فيه
الفانيلات والتيشرتات الخاصه بكريستيانو
رونالدو بالاضافه الى المتجر الرسمي هنالك
متجر الكترونيه بيع في هذا التيشيرت
لكريستيانو رونالدو بدا من صفقه الانتقال
من اعلانها مباشره تم وضع عدد من
الفانيلات الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو مع
نادي النصر الا انها نفذ بشكل كامل
فبالتالي يتم الاستعانه
بطريقه اخرى
لتوفير هذا التيشيرت للمشجعين باسرع وقت
ممكن الطريقه الاخرى ان ياتي المشجع
مباشره ويشتري تيشيرت او فانيلا بدون رقم
وبدون اسم اي لاعب بعد ذلك ينتقل الى
المرحله همم الثانيه وهي مرحله الطباعه
وفيها يتواجد عدد من موظفي المتجر الرسمي
ويطبع اسم كريستيانو ورقمه مباشره
ليستلمها المشجع لضافه الى تواجد الموقع
همم الالكتروني الذي تتوفر فيه التيشيرتات
قريبا ولكن حتى الان همم لم يتم توفير عدد
كبير من التيشرتات وهي ليست متوفره حتى
هذه اللحظه الكثير من الجماهير يطالبون
بتوفيرها باقرب همم لحظه وبعده ضخم من همم
الارقام لكي يتسنى لكل محبي ومشجعين
كريستيانو رونالدو الحصول على هذا
التيشيرت وهمم
وشراي مباشره سواء من المتجر الكترونيه
وحتى من متجر النادي
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض ااه صعب
انك تحصله يعني انا اخذت اربعه الحين
هذا يعتبر شيء تاريخي انا ابغى اتكلم
بالمناسبه على المتجر الالكتروني بصراحه
انا لاحظت كثير بتويتر انه ما بواحد او
اثنين لا فوق المياه تطلب يدخلون المتجر
الكتروني بلاجانب واللغه تكون عربيه
متوفر بالمتجر الكتروني فسبقه كبيره
عالميه زي كده يفترض انك وفرت هذا شيء
بالمتجر كان لغه انجليزيه متوفر من زمان
وبرده
[موسيقى]
فهد الشهري مراسل العربيه معنا الان من
الرياض لاطلاعنا على المزيد من التفاصيل
والمعلومات حول وصول النجم العالمي
كريستيانو رونالدو الى الرياض للالتحاق
بنادي النصر فهد مرحبا بك اي تفاصيل
اضافيه
[موسيقى]
القريبه القادمه الكابتن كريستيانو
رونالدو كريستيانو رونالدو الى نادي النصر
حيث نحن الان على بوابه الدخول للطيران
الخاصه في مطار الملك خالد للرياض الجو
ممطر جميل همم ينتظر الجمهور السعودي كافه
والجمهور النصراوي بشكل خاص سهول اللاعب
اللي اعتقد انه الان في المدرج همم يهون
ان شاء الله اجراءات الوصول والاوراق
الرسميه وبيكون ان شاء الله بعدها متجه
الى سكن والخاص استعداد الحفل الكبير اللي
راح يقام ان شاء الله في الساعه السابعه
في استاد مرسول مبارك بالرياض ااه وصول
الى جماهيري بعيد عن الانظار الجمهور
ممنوع الدخول الى صاله مطار الجماهير
وايضا تم منع الاعلام من الدخول الى هناك
وتصوير همم كريستيانو همم احنا نتواجد على
مسافه همم تبعد تقريبا
كيلو ونصف مسار الطيران الخاصه
قديش في تفاعل من يعني خاصه عمر الشباب
المهتمين المولاعين بالرياضه
بقميص كريستيانو رونالدو كما قلنا الان
بتهافت على نادي النصر اكثر الان مقارنه
بالانديه الاخرى اللي لها ايضا جماهيرها
ومتابعينها بالسعوديه
تفاعل كبير طاهر يعني اخرها من اول ما
اعلن تعاقد الكابت كريستيانو رونالدو مع
نادي النصر كان في اعلان لتذاكر مباريات
النصر الطائي اللي راح تقام الخميس القادم
في الدوري توقع ظهور اول ثواني في المدرج
او في الملعب على حسب جاهزيه الكابتن
كريستيانو نافذه تذاكر طاهر بعد اربع
ساعات فقط الملعب كامله 25,000 الان الحفل
همم دخلت قبل قليل انا قبل تقريبا قبل نصف
ساعه ممكن اوريك عندي حاولت ان ابحث عن
تذكره كان ال- اا ال- اا طاهر شوف
كان ااا اذا يشوف الرقم هنا
الانتظار 120,000
على تذاكر
مباراه شكرا
اللي انت فيه راح نكتفي بهذا القدر ولكن
نتابع رياضيا مع زياد عبيدات بعد قليل فهد
الشهري مراسل العربيه من الرياض شكرا
جزيلا الى زياد
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا طاهر واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
وصل قبل قليل اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى العاصمه السعوديه رياض قديما
من مدريد تمهيدا للعب مع نادي النصر
السعودي
وينتظر ان يقدم النادي لعبه الجديد الى
الجماهير غدا الثلاثاء في ملعب مرسول
مباركه وسط حضور جماهيريين واعلاميين كبير
من داخل السعوديه وخارجها وبحسب صحيفه
الرياضيه المتخصصه سيلقي كريستيانو خلال
الحفل كلمه قصيره يخاطب فيها جماهير نادي
الجديد
ونشار كريستيانو رونالدو لاعب نادي النصر
السعودي مقطع فيديو على حسابه الشخصي في
انستغرام اللاعب البرتغاليه وجهها رساله
الى جماهير نادي النصر في طائراته الخاصه
المتجهه الى الرياض للانتقال الى فريقه
النصر قائلا اراكم قريبا
ونشرت جورجينا رودريغيز عارضته الازياء
وصديقه اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو صورا في حسابها شخصيه على
انستغرام قبل اقلاع الطائره واطلت جورجينا
بصور لها برفقه ابنائها داخل الطائره
الخاصه
تقدم النادي الاهلي الى صداره الدوري
المصري لكره القدم بعد تغلبه على بيراميدز
بثلاثه اهداف مقابل لا شيء او الاهداف
اللقاء في هذه المباراه سجله عمر السليه
عند الدقيقه التاسعه عشر
وعدا اللاعب نفسه
واضاف الهدف الثاني عند الدقيقه التاسعه
والستين لفريقه النادي الاهلي
وتتم حسين الشحات اهداف الاهلي بتسجيله
الهدف الثالث ليرفع الاهلي رصيده الى 27
نقطه وتجمد بيراميدز عند نقطه ال 20
وتعرض الزمالك الخساره امام اسوان بهدفين
مقابل هدف واحد ضمن الجوله في الحاديه عشر
من الدوري المصري لكره القدم دقيقه
الرابعه اعلنت عن اول اهداف اللقاء لمصلحه
اسوان عن طريق محمد عبد الغني بالخطا في
مرماه هو شهد الوقت بدل الضائع للشوط
الاول الهدف الثاني لفريق اسوان عن طريق
كمونيين فيما احرز حسام عبد المجيد هدف
تخليص الفارق للزمالك عند الدقيقه السادسه
والخمسين بهذه النتيجه توقف رصيد الزمالك
عند 24 نقطه فيما يحتل اسوان المركز
السابع بخمسه عشر نقطه
ضمن الجوله التاسعه عشر من الدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم يستقبل
ارسنال فريق نيوكاسل يونايتد ويحتل ارسنال
المركز الاول في جدول الترتيب برصيد 43
نقطه مقابل 34 نقطه لفريق اليوكاسل
يونايتد صاحب المركز الثالث
وسيكون مانشستر يونايتد على موعد مع ضيفه
بورن موثق الجوله التاسعه عشر من الدوري
الانجليزي وفاز شياطين الحمر في اخر ثلاث
مباريات للمسابقات ويحتل المركز الرابع
برصيد اثنتين وثلاثين نقطه في ما خسر بورن
موثق في الجوله الماضيه امام كريستال
بالاس وياتي في المركز الخامس عشر في
الترتيب العام برصيد سته عشر نقطه
تصدر المتسابقه القطري ناصر العطيه
المرحله الثانيه مران لذكار المقام حاليا
في السعوديه وانهى بطل نسخه الماضيه من
الرالي المرحله التي انطلقت من ينبع
وانتهت في العلا به مسافه وصلت الى 500
و88 كم في المركز الاول في ما تصدر
الفرنسي الكسندر هيرو فئه الاكواد ومعتز
على امريكيه كلاين المركز الاول في فئه
الدراجه الناريه وحصل الامريكي الاخر من
جوه ثري على صداره فئه
الهولنديه
في الدراجات
تواصل نعشق الاسطوره البرازيلي فيليه الى
ملعب نادي سانتوس حيث سيبدا النادي الذي
لعب له الراحل معظم مسيرته مراسم التشييع
في الملعب اليوم الاثنين
وستقوم الجماهير بالقاء النظره الاخيره
على بيليه لمده 24 ساعه وبعد انتهاء مراسم
القاء النظره الاخيره سيمر موكب الجنازه
عبر شوارع سانتوس
ورئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم مراسم
جنازه الاسطوره فيليه وكان رئيس فيفا من
اول من القى التحيات امام الناس المفتوح
للاسطوره البرازيليه والذي تم عرضه في
منتصف الملعب بحضور رؤساء اتحاد كره القدم
في امريكا الجنوبيه واعضاء الاتحاد
البرازيلي للعبه
في مؤتمر الصحفي بعد جميع دول العالم
لتسميه احد ملاعبها لكره القدم باسمها
الاسطوره الراحله
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك طاهر
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك زياد مع انه كان فيك تسلم صهيب
مباشره لانه نحن خلصنا كمان ههه هو حدك
احسن اقرب ههه
لابد من المرور عليك يا طاهر منيحه شكرا
جزيلا خبر الساعه طبعا سيبقى وصول
كريستيانو رونالدو الى السعوديه اليك شكرا